and so it'd be useful to see that
um I think given you know Nigel's
already uh cancer Mark has already
alluded to it Labor's Manifesto was
essentially still three words so perhaps
the kind of lack of detail here isn't
isn't isn't that surprising
um but I'm worried that some of those
statements are so vague that they sort
of lose all meaning there's a lot of
kind of motherhood and apple pie a lot
of just doing the day job from my
perspective and it's sort of a list of a
lot of things that we should be doing as
a council but I'm worried that there's
not enough ambition as to how we go
further and how we deliver more
um councilor Burkin was very uh
persistent in reminding us that when we
sent out papers at short notice like
this uh that it wasn't acceptable and I
hope that he will be consistent in
agreeing with me on that point to have
these papers on Friday uh is is not
really good enough in my in my own point
of view
um I was aware obviously that they were
going to cabinet so I checked the
cabinet papers in advance to Friday but
we have a lot of new councilors here who
weren't aware of that so
um the first our group saw of this was
only or most of our group that only
thought of this was sort of uh towards
the back end of last week
um the key thing that I'm most concerned
about is the lack of consultation though
this is the the last council plan that
was brought for Council in 2019 followed
five weeks of consultation public
consultation huge amount of activity
there was a press release there were
radio interviews staff and member
drop-ins an article in the news magazine
social media all those sorts of things
and we had quite a decent response rate
um the council is about to consider an
item on incorporate in collaboration and
being open and transparent
but where there's where's the evidence
of this on the council plan
and on that basis I think the
conservative group will abstain we
recognize it's your Administration we
don't want to stand in the way of your
council plan but from our perspective
um you know we think that this it being
the first council plan is not necessary
in the in the in the county for example
is not necessarily the best thing we
would have preferred actually more time
being taken a more collaborative
approach more opportunity for more
members to feed in and public
consultation to ensure that it met with
the the views of local residents thank
you Jeff
thank you any other comment or questions
Council Shipman
thank you chair um
I I agree with everyone that spoke so
far in that the aims are admirable
um but I think the managing director
referenced in the services there was a
detailed document somewhere and I was
expecting that to be to be sent out with
this and we don't seem to have got it so
we're just voting on a set of aims at
the moment without any detail as to how
we're going to achieve any of them and I
think we really could have done with
that in advance of this debate so we
know we all know what we're voting for
and I feel that that's been missed so
I'm kind of in a bit of a predicament
whether to vote for it or against it at
the moment
Council Cupid
[Music]
okay
I don't know why it's so far forward
yeah thank you
um yeah just to I think I agree with
um a lot of the points that councilor
Dales made that this seems to be lacking
in detail appreciate councilor Shipman's
comments about there may be a more
detailed document behind it but again
would expect us local as elective
members that we would have seen that and
I think that you know it feels rushed
you councilor bark has just mentioned
that you're the first Council to bring
this forward it's not a race it's about
what matters isn't it so
um I think agreeing with councilor
Dale's uh comments about the lack of
consultation and engagement of this I
don't I don't think any of us here today
would disagree with the headline aims
but I think you've had three months
already and it doesn't really seem like
there's anything behind them in this
plan certainly with what we've been
presented uh with today and as councilor
Dale said most of it seems to be
pledging to do things we did without
taking them to the next stage or
progressing them or statutory things
such as the food
um service plans Etc and I'm just as a
final big point I'm quite concerned by
the key to topics that are missing from
this appreciate you can't have
everything because it'd be rooms and
Marines long but you don't want to
mention the clay Crosstown deal
regeneration car parking which I will
come on to later and most notably you
never mention anything to do with growth
or our town centers I'm sure our local
businesses and shops will be quite
disappointed with that and I certainly
am and you don't really mention any of
our specific places in Northeast
Derbyshire other than in the the sort of
factual intro we have a really diverse
and fantastic deal and it seems to me
like this plan sort of doesn't doesn't
recognize that and it could be a general
plan for anywhere with the headline aim
and just as a final point I think what
encapsulates all the points I've made
most clearly for me is the typos and
grammatical errors throughout this I
don't blame anyone for any typos but as
a key Council document that you're going
to work from for the next four years and
be a whole accountable to I would have
expected a little bit of proofreading
and I've been happy to help with that so
um in line with with Council Dale's
comments respect the Democratic mandate
that you've got but as a as a member
today I can't support this while I'm
staying Thanks Jen thank you
councilor Hancock
foreign
thank you chair um if on behalf of our
group because I was the only one who
worked with Clive um if you could pass
our condolence arm as well it was a very
nice gentleman and a pleasure to know
um again I raised him business scrutiny
that there's no detail here at all and
um it is style of substance we've got a
nice pretty looking document with lots
of nice colors but absolutely nothing to
tell us how it's going to be done and
again I'm going to pick up on what a
couple of other members have said
already
councilor barkers kind of said well
let's get it here it has been rushed
it's been put through to us and this
really should have been probably a
quarter a quarter into the uh into this
year
when we've had time to do a consultation
we've had time to actually go properly
through scrutiny because I mean one of
the key things that's been pushed so far
is that everything should go through
scrutiny and cabinet while this was
delivered to scrutiny it wasn't debated
by scrutiny certainly are by the
business scrutiny committee we were told
this was what was going on it was
presented so
well
we're not even living up to our own
words already
and you'll have comments or questions
but
not Council Barker to reply
yeah yeah thank you uh thanks for those
comments uh like I said it's an evolving
document this we wanted to hit the
ground running which we've done uh it's
uh it's a document there in front of us
uh I know Lee's West Community there are
some details at the back of that that
are being formulated I think as we speak
Leanne and uh we'll all get started to
them we we are trying to align scrutiny
up with this so we will have input uh
all councils will be able to have input
in our how this evolves uh so I'm I'm
more than confident that this is a good
thing we're also looking at the kpis the
key performance indicators for people
that don't know what that is uh because
we want to align them better as well so
we're not just counting beans it says
for a reason those performance
indicators need to be specific to what
we what we're trying to achieve and
I'm more than happy for this uh this
council plan to uh to be passed today
and thank you for your comments did you
answer anything Lee on that sorry Connie
yeah well go on then
I'll just pick up
uh just pick up a couple of those I mean
apologies first of all there are a
couple of typos councilor Coopers
correct uh I don't think he's been
rushed but certainly probably ambitious
is is one way of describing it and
trying to present back to the public
um I guess what this Administration
um they felt they were elected upon so a
lot of time and effort's gone into this
it's certainly not been rushed there's a
hell of a lot that is not on the table
at this point I I'll grant that huge
spreadsheets that contains uh the detail
with particularly held off around the
Performance Management framework rather
than trying to shoe horn things into a
Performance Management framework it's
been clear we've been clear throughout
this period that we want to be clear
what we're trying to do and then build a
Performance Management framework around
that so that's all work that's happening
at the moment into all four scrutinies
and explained uh that period of time
that we're in the middle of now but
that'll run until early Autumn or the
granular detail will be contained there
or the Performance Management framework
and everything else I think this was
about making that statement that outward
facing document to say you said we're
doing I guess I guess that's it yeah
thank you thank you
so we now move to the vote all those in
favor
all those against
any abstentions
and that is carried
thank you
so item eight is the council scrutiny
committee so we're going to ask the
assistant director of governance and the
monitoring officer Mrs Sternberg to
introduce this please
thank you chair
this follows on from the previous item
on council plan at the annual meeting
Council approved the establishment of
four scrutiny committees the areas and
themes of these committees relate
directly to the council plan objectives
Etc at the time no terms of reference
had been developed since then the terms
of reference have been developed and
discussed with each of the four scrutiny
committees they have also been
considered by standards committee they
are now before you for approval and for
adding to the Constitution thank you
thank you certainly the document needs
to be proposed and seconded so Council
Gillette
thank you and do you have a second
Council Burton thank you so any comments
All questions
Council Dale
thank you uh very much Jay I think just
just given the above comments about or
the previous comments rather about the
council plan I'm concerned about
limiting scrutiny committees to only
following the lead of the council plan
obviously we talked about the council
plan lacking a degree of that detail so
how exactly those scrutiny committees
are going to scrutinize that without the
data I understand that the comments that
that will come but it's difficult to say
at this stage how that's going to work
and how that's going to interact and I'd
be concerned that agendas of committees
might be quite light and lacking in
Focus if that's the only if they're if
they're limited to quite a narrow aspect
to the council plan each
previously we always used to do an
annual review at every every excuse me
committee I'm not necessarily saying
that's the best things I think actually
that made scrutiny committees not as
agile as they as they perhaps needed to
be so I'm not suggesting necessarily
that's the best thing but at least it
gave it a specific kind of focus uh so
it'd be interesting to know whether how
we're going to sort of give that
um that Focus to it whether it's a
quarterly review or something like that
I think would be interesting to know
um and I just I feel like scrutiny
committees are being limited a little
bit in terms of this uh in terms of this
approach that they should be independent
they should be able to operate as they
see fit it feels a little bit like a
straight jacket to be honest uh and not
sort of open and collaborative and
transparent
um I think just an example
um what about issues that aren't covered
in the in the council plan just to give
an example of my own personal experience
our council plan was produced before we
had covid before we had the town deal
um and you know what how will scrutiny
committees be able to respond to those
sorts of issues that arrive post the
council plan being adopted and be able
to scrutinize them and I'm sort of
worried that that solidifies a kind of
blind spot you know if we if we
purposely exclude stuff that's not in
that document how do
scrutiny committee I'm a bit unsure as
to the purpose of that I mean the budget
is mentioned as a as a as a topic that
might be scrutinized but obviously
what's the purpose of audit there no
audit is is there to scrutinize the
budget if we've got another committee
that's set up to uh screen it has the
budget I'm slightly concerned that's
devaluing the role of audit
um so I think on that basis we're
struggling to vote for these changes I
think we no not not against uh changing
scrutiny's terms of reference and and
changing How We Do scrutiny I think
that's that's to be welcome but
concerned about limiting it solely to a
council Council Plan Focus thank you
chair can you hear the comments or
questions
now I'm going to ask councilor Gillett
to respond
I think the first point to make is that
this document doesn't supersede any of
the other Council the rules in the
council Constitution with regards to the
agenda and how items get on the agenda
uh as far as I'm aware they are still
there
um this is obviously a living document
counselor Dale it's a new document it
the council Constitution is reviewed
annually so by this time next year it
will have been looked at again all we've
done at standards is simply take on
board the comments they'll come through
from the Committees that excuse me
committees and and the officer
recommendations if they proves to be any
serious problems with with these terms
of reference I I would expect us to look
at them again this is as I say this is a
living document that won't change and
adapt
um it allows the exclusion committees to
kick off their workload rather than
waiting for things to happen in the
first instance and obviously we've heard
already about the links for the council
plan and making sure that the council
plan is implemented in in the way that
Council wants it to be implemented as
well so while your comments or your
concerns may be understandable at this
stage hopefully if there are any issues
we'll line them out over the next 12
months
thank you I think there is a technical
issue around audit I think Mrs Sternberg
if you could elaborate please
thank you chair yes previously the
budget has gone to the audit and
corporate governance scrutiny this
fulfills the function the budget going
to scrutiny to be scrutinized as we've
separated out the audit committee and
there's no longer a scrutiny committee
as well we need an arrangement in place
for scrutiny to consider the budget as
part of the budget policy framework and
this is what we're you know put in The
Proposal
thank you for that so um been proposed
and seconded all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
and that is carried thank you
so item nine values in the Constitution
back to you Mr Sternberg
thank you chair again this follows on
from the council plan item the report
sets out the extra value that sorry the
values that are in the Constitution and
also outlines the new one that is
proposed via the council plan standards
committee has considered this and
recommended it for inclusion in the
Constitution and it's here before you
for that decision thank you chair
thank you so we need a proposer
councilor Barker yet can I propose that
please and
again just just I'm moving that there is
a genuine uh desire to be uh open and
transparent as as
much as we can be going forward and now
we have this this thing with you know a
council meetings and it's about me and
you wherever there's a lot of other
people in this room and it's about
changing that culture so that people
feel they've got a a voice in the
council irrespective of of whether
you're back venture or on the cabinet or
on the Shadow or so it's all that and uh
while we're moving that that fifth one
which is being collaborative open and
transparent we also need to take notices
the other fours that are still there so
hopefully we can uh we can live up to
those expectations as well so I'll move
the recommendation in one that we
approve the edition of the fifth value
thank you thank you and a second there
Council Birkin thank you Council Burkin
any comments or questions I'm going to
go to council adlington Stringer first
just for a change of voice for a moment
Council day I'll then come back to you
thank you
um my only observation was that open is
now including the values twice
the first value includes the word open
just wonder if that's a little bit
repetitive and we could be a bit more
creative
thank you very true very that's just
I'll come back to you Council Rock
anymore there's some more questions
counselor Dale
thank you chair uh councilor Abington
string is more eager glad to know
because I didn't even noticed that I
wasn't going to say that so I think from
my perspective obviously we will vote
for this you know no one can argue with
the sentiments within that I think what
I would say though is that actions speak
louder than words clearly we're grateful
for the the collaborative approach so
far in terms of the sharing of Vice
chairs absolutely but we have already
seen on this agenda a council plan that
hasn't had consultation I'm not sure how
open that's been or collaborative in
terms of working with the district to uh
to produce that so
um yeah as I say we will vote for the
recommendations but obviously remains to
be seen how how well we we do on that
front
thank you any other comments
councilor Shipman
thank you chair
um I'll just repeat what I said in the
scrutiny committee on this um I agree
with cancer Dale that actions do speak
louder than words and when it comes to
being open and transparent and
collaborative being aware that that's
been put in there
um and this Administration is trying to
promote
if you look at the allocations of the
vice chairs that have gone out there's
one group on this Council that's not got
any representation on that front when
all the other ones have been included I
won't say that's collaborative I always
say that's purposely exclude in one
group whilst trying to be collaborative
or at least trying to show to be
collaborative with the rest
um and I will Point cancel the market to
the motion that was passed at the last
meeting which put restrictions on
motions that come to this Council
chamber which was something that
backbench councilors had an opportunity
to bring any motion they wanted forward
each council meeting
and again that was passed so I'm
struggling a little bit to understand
where this openness transparent and
collaborative Administration is coming
from when the action so far have told a
different story
thank you Council Shipman any other
comments
Council Barker to reply all right thank
you
and yeah the proof will be in the
brewery now I accept that Alex I think
that's fair regarding the uh the other
thing Council shipment I think from our
perspective if we are going to be
collaborative and all this I think we've
got to trust the people that we're
working with and and on several
occasions you've
you've let me down on that so hence the
decision that we made at the last
meeting
uh and yeah they're uh the motion I
think there's been a long time coming
regarding the restrictions it's I think
that's going through standards and
things like that so uh it's something
again we can we can keep reviewing the
standards committee and if that's not
working but there is a genuine
commitment to change that culture at the
council about working better and
involving bike range counselors more in
the process through scrutiny or whatever
that's what we're trying to achieve
thank you
thank you it's been proposed and
seconded all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
and that is carried
item 10 schedule of meetings for 23 24.
so back to assistant director of
governance and monitoring officer please
thank you chair uh an interim schedule
meetings was agreed at the annual
Council including this meeting it was
clear that changes the proposed schedule
meetings were needed these have now been
worked through with members and the
proposed scheduled meetings until May
2024 is recommended for approval by
Council thank you Jeff
thank you can we have someone move those
councilor Burkin thank you
thank you and do you have a second day
yeah okay councilor Barker any comments
or questions
been proposed and seconded all those in
favor
anyone against
any abstentions
and that is carried so item 11 the stone
broom Community governance review
back to you Mrs Sternberg thank you
chair
the report sets out the history of this
matter this started with a petition to
council to consider establishing a
separate Stone Brewing Parish Council
considerable consultation has been
carried out and details are included in
the report in the report attachments and
paperwork in the members room
the executive summary of the analysis of
the survey results is included in the
report and the parish council letter is
attached to the report the
recommendations leave you with a choice
you can either choose a the
establishment of a separate Stone Parish
Council
um
or alternatively you could choose
recommendation B not to set up a
separate Stone room Parish Council there
will then be a need to publish your
decision for everybody to see and to
contact people who have expressed an
interest to tell them the result
recommendation tools with are to date
might have suggest that it is left open
so that a report on the further outcome
of the publication can be presented when
the consultation or when the information
has been sent to relevant people
recommendation three repeats the
existing delegation to the managing
director so that officers are able to
move the process on between Council
meetings including if necessary revising
the timetable thank you chair
thank you do we have a proposal for the
report Council Burkin
please yeah thank you do you have a
second if that yes I'll take that thank
you any comments or questions you want
to do that
yeah
um just like to thank the previous
working group and election staff will
put an awful amount of work into this
into this project
um a lot of consultations take in Place
several by several methods leaflets
through the media meetings unfortunately
relatively few people took part in the
consultation
and again when the when the second round
of consultations had to be taken place
as well
um so the feeling is is generally there
that the case hasn't been made as such
um what I would be recommending is that
we choose
option b which is not to establish a
separate Stormborn Parish Council but at
the same time I'd like to make a
recommendation that we amend this to say
that the council will consider warding
children in Highland Parish Council
before the next elections in May 27th
thank you so also I'll check those emm
site Amendment and the
the decision to go with not establishing
a separate Council
are we all clear about that
so a council Cupid first and then
Council weatherall
foreign
thank you chat um I'm happy to to
support that recommendation today I
think it's fair to say as one of the
local board members and I don't know if
the other mobile like Auburn would want
to come in that following the uh parish
council elections in May I think there
has been a change of dynamic on the
parish council there's been a change of
personnel there's still a lot of
experienced Personnel uh there as well
uh but it feels a little bit different
and certainly whilst I wouldn't say I've
spoken to everybody in in Stoneboro
Stone boom or in the parish I've spoken
to some people and they sort of said you
know what we're quite happy to see how
it goes it would seem a little bit
strange to separate and do another
um sort of election and move into the
costs of that Etc I know as we discussed
before I think what what I would ask
though is
um that we sort of and uh sort of seek
the the guidance of the monitoring
officer and also the proposal and
secondary that alongside the warding
point that we uh because I understand
that if we say no today it sort of
closes it off so I wonder if there's a
way for a couple of years I'm seeking
sort of clarity on this in a second um
if there's a way to sort of pass it back
to the parish council to feed back on if
there's still a sort of level of concern
so that if the parish council decide to
do a referendum or whatever in the
future that the district council would
re-look at it so I don't know if there's
a way that we can sort of keep it open
rather than closing it off in in the
recommendations so that if there is
feeling you know in in a year's time or
whatever that it could be re-looked at
rather than closed off so that's that's
all I'd ask for but otherwise Happy to
support the recommendations thank you I
think I know I said Council weather all
next but I'm sure you won't mind if I
ask Mrs Sternberg just to respond to
that point
thank you chair
um no there wouldn't be a way for you to
make a non-decision today you have to
decide
um but you you speak about the two years
that's quite right that's two years from
the petition which was last year so it's
a lot sooner than you think and then
another Community governance where you
could be carried out if that was the
wish
thank you Council weatherall
yeah just a question
is that some yeah yeah just a question
um I can see legal implications have
been added um are there any financial
implications for us to consider
come on
let's just stand back in terms of making
a decision not to have well either way
either way in terms of if a decision not
to have a stone room Parish Council is
just the cost of your office's time Etc
sorting out the rest of it if there were
to be a new phone boom Parish Council
considerably more effort would have to
be put in by a variety of officers
including my finance colleagues to help
separate the two councils out in terms
of you know is there a particular cost
for a fee for something no but there
would be a lot of work in that respect
councilor Hancock
thanks I think just actually to pick up
on Mrs sternberg's point there there
would be a slight change it would
actually reduce the cost of by-elections
if we weren't with awarded Parish
because obviously if there was a
by-election it would only be that Ward
so there would actually be a minor
reduction that way
um I have to be honest my sympathies are
a little bit more with counselor cupid
here because I think we do kind of need
a little bit of a let's try it and see
particularly given the fact that we've
already said there's a change purely on
the whim of of a different set of people
on there to what was there before so
there are kind of concerns in terms of
long term but I think warding is kind of
a decent interim option so with that
Amendment I'd be happy to support it
Council Foster
thank you chair uh yeah as the chair of
the previous uh working group on this
along with councilor Rothman councilor
Welton I'm more than happy to support
this recommendation uh I think uh
councilors that were here at the last
Administration will remember my
arguments and my recommendations uh as
the chair of that working group and
um yeah this makes complete sense so
very happy to support it
um there was just no grounds full of
opinion the numbers just weren't there
and that that's what it was so it was a
it was a really non-political open
transparent recommendation last time so
we're very happy to to support that as
for the um
the idea of a referendum it's something
nice that when I spoke to the last uh
Parish Council before the elections uh
of Charlotte and I am it's something I
put to the councils there as something
they could do and that they should
consider that'd be the next step for me
I know it's not a governance step but it
was like the next Common Sense moral
step if you like so that's something I
put forward there
um so yeah really happy to support this
thank you chair thank you
any other comment Council Shipman I'm
just wondered if the monitoring officer
gives some guidance on whether awarding
it's a possibility because I thought
Wards only came when district and County
um Wards crossed each other and
therefore it created a ward within that
Parish are we can we just have wards
wherever we decide
well I'm not saying that it's definite
in this case but yes we can certainly
look at it as the principal Council in
relation to Parish councils that's
something we can review so yes
any other comments
what councilor Burkin to reply
no no guys thank you yeah I'll take them
so we moved recommendations and just be
clear it's one b and that's part of
recommendations
and the warding element that we've heard
about that's been added today
so all those in favor
[Music]
anyone against
any abstentions
then that is carried thank you
so we move to item 12 which are
questions asked from Members under
procedure rule 9.2 so we're going to
start with question a it's up to you
whether you want to read your question
in full or you're submitting your
question as written and you don't have
to read it out so first question a is
canceling it to counselor Pickering
that's really good thank you uh yes
counselor Pickering I just wanted to ask
um do you intend to honor the
conservative group commitment to
emptying the green bins for 12 months of
the year straight through thank you
Council Pickering to respond
thank you very much for your question
um it asks if we're going to honor a
commitment
um a question that there was a
commitment what we saw is some dithering
about for nearly four years and a
headline appeared just before the
election that's not really a commitment
but it is electioneering
um and I think it was not very
responsibly thought out
um that the 12-month bit before you made
a promise to uh residents of Northeast
Derbyshire but that's been the
conservative position all along to make
unfulfilled promises however
um we've just consulted with residents
through the citizens panel on waste
delivery and we'll listen to that shape
the services accordingly we have in the
council plan that's just being approved
today committed to providing an
effective and efficient waste collection
um and um if you've not seen it in there
are can announce that we've reduced the
suspension period by three weeks
um and that's on the bin collection
schedule what we will do
um is undertake to determine if the
amount of garden and food waste
collected between December and March
actually justifies the amount of CO2
um that's released by those Vehicles
driving around to do that in our council
plan we've agreed to be well we've
promised to be cleaner and Greener and
we'll try to live up to that
responsibility rather than just make off
the cuff promises for 12 months
um waste collection
thank you
Council again wish to ask a
supplementary
um well I'm very disappointed to be
honest
um as you know I represent Aurora award
which a lot of us do uh I also I think
most people know that I work as a
gardener tree surgeon and I'm well aware
that climate change is making our
Gardens behave very differently
um I mean I'm personally still mowing in
December and then of course we have seem
to be having twice as much as cutting
back thanks to all right you have a
question please sorry well not really no
I'm just
not very happy that I don't think it's
cleaner or greener
it's not a question it's Council
Pickering would you want to respond to
that well it's uh not a question is it
really but uh you see what council
liglet is actually indicating is the
overall view of what the Tory policy and
philosophy on climate change is they're
in denial of some of it
um and just because she has a few more
grass clippings to clean up doesn't mean
to say that we should continue to
pollute the district unnecessarily
thank you question B counselor Cupid
your question please
thank you chair
um I don't I don't need to read it out
Council of Arkansas
yeah yeah and and the short answer is
yes
[Laughter]
there is it's only one scheme that will
form part of ambitious affordable
housing growth plans as I mentioned in
me uh Bishop beginning we are looking at
acquiring and building more more Council
houses uh not just in in stone room I
also I went I didn't understand that
were there any time scales attached to
these Bungalows or not but if they're
we're open in the very near future there
will be so yes we are definitely
going on with the stone room Bungalows
and I can see you've got a supplementary
question Council Cupid thank you chair
and thank you Council Barker that's
there are there were draft
times of submission of a planning
application and then and then obviously
writtenald uh in terms of implementation
just just as a sort of supplementary
question obviously recognizing that
there are a lot of vulnerable and
elderly residents in that area uh many
of whom have spent their entire lives in
stonebroom and all their families live
there it is going to be a challenge in
terms of a replacement project and a
need to do it sensitively so can I just
get your sort of formal commitment as
well that you'll commit to working with
myself councilor Leggett and councilor
Rowe to keep us updated and to work with
us on the replacement scheme given the
work we've put into it and the sort of
relationships we've forged with with
residents and retinal today Council
Market
I'm more than happy with that I was
involved with the the original thing the
bungalows in eckington and kilimash and
it was difficult to keep people
happy that I lived in those prefabs they
wanted to live next door to the person
that they delivering till now and it
would Hardware but the
uh Community involvement people at right
now were brilliant they did everything
they could and are more than happy for
you to be involved whoever's involved in
that because it is difficult they all
want replacing but the people have lived
there a long while and it's very
sensitive
thank you thank you question C so
councilor Foster your question for
Council Barry please uh yeah thank you
chair
uh yeah the UK shared Prosperity fund
designed to replace the EU structural
funding this is monies from central
government for those that don't know uh
given to districts and borrowers to
distribute some 2.6 billion over three
years
that's the cost of the contrary
I'm sorry I'm having difficulty with
this with this microphone
yeah
okay yeah Northeast Derbyshire was given
2.58 million out of that to spend over
that three years the last Administration
made some allocations across the
district uh my my question relates to
this
and I'll read it out for instance to the
portfolio holder councilor Barry will
the portfolio holder confirm that the
new Administration will honor the
financial commitments already made by
the council in relationship relation to
its allocation of the UK shared
Prosperity fund and the investment plan
thank you chair Council Barry to reply
well in the same response as Nigel is
yes uh basically we will be honoring and
delivering the Northeast Derbyshire UK's
Prosperity fund investment plan which
will cover Three Financial years which
is
2022-2025. as the program time scale
suggests all funding needs to be spent
by March 2025 officers and I are mindful
of that and working hard to ensure that
the priorities and contracted outputs
and outcomes are delivered I've planned
this includes regularly monitoring
progress of supported activity and
setting deadlines for provisional offers
where much funding is required
if any challenges arise which affect the
ability of the projects to be delivered
within the required time scales then
cabinet members will consider
alternative Solutions which
appropriately achieve the contracted
criteria of the UK SPF investment plan
as previously established this may turn
they in turn create opportunities of a
new applications and activity to come
forward which we will publicize as
appropriate thank you supplementary I do
have one chair thank you uh I think what
I'm looking for is uh reassurance around
two specific geographical areas I'm
looking for a reassurance for the people
of eckington around the 200 000 that was
there mark for Lansbury Park in
particular and secondly for the 500 000
or 19 of the fund which was allocated to
improvements to town Centers High
streets Paving Landscaping Street
Furniture lighting and public art this
was uh this was with privacy Focus given
to dronfield or rather dronfield Civic
Center so my question is uh will this
council is this Council still committed
specifically this if we can make a
record of this is it still committed to
spending 200 000 in eckington
and 500 000 in drumfield on the Civic
Center councilor Barry thank you chair
again yes
prior to the election the last
Administration made funding offers to
several parish and town councils that
required much funding in order to
deliver these projects these councils
all have until the end of September to
confirm their plans and to show that the
match funding is in place
this is to manage the risk of being able
to deliver a scheme by December
24. the same time scales apply to
eckington Parish Council for Lansbury
Park we're hopeful that all the parishes
can secure and confirm the additional
funding by that deadline and come back
with their detailed and costed delivery
plans cabinet members will consider the
next steps if they are unable to achieve
this
so that's in relation to the eckington
one in relation to the drum field
officer officers are currently trying to
engage with local landowners for the
development of our priority site
if these attempts are not successful our
time scales mean that the development is
not possible then cabinet members will
consider how best to address the
position at the appropriate time in
order to meet its spend and output
commitments
hope that answers your question
thank you just to point out that um
under item 12 which is questions from
members in according to Constitution it
is time Limited
we have just gone to 15 minutes
so I think on this occasion I'm going to
allow the two further questions but in
future once your 15 minutes is up it's
up
so this is because it's still still
relatively finding our way with a new
Council and so I'm going to allow
question D and question e but please
don't read them out
so counselor Dale's question to
councilor Barker as read so that's
question d
Council Market to respond Hey Kevin
as read can I go yeah that's why I said
Council Market to respond thank you
I didn't know about that 15 minutes for
the question there you go anyway uh I
honestly couldn't believe this question
it's when on the same day I got this on
my desk
uh it will same day as County Council
announced they wouldn't put School meals
up by 40 percent
and it will I I can't believe that
that's it if it works you're serious
it'd be laughable it wouldn't be funny
but uh
I could go on about out the present Tory
governments to help cause this cost of
living challenge as they call it
uh but I won't
to answer your question more
specifically well accept that some good
work has done prior to the election
which of course we will continue to do
and build on
however since the election we have done
several things first and foremost we're
in reinstated the grant to Davison
employee Worker Center
and we're aware of the great work they
do in helping people navigate the very
complex welfare arts and benefits
systems and also also I noted on the
newly adopted council plan we will
support existing and new businesses to
support new and existing jobs
we're also looking at further
community-led support through the uh
your Prosperity fund which will focus on
the social Financial inclusion
also I know Rick nor they're working
with our tenants helping with all the
cost of living issues they're
experiencing and hopefully you can rest
assured that we are indeed making
meaningful progress in help helping
people with the government in deals
crisis thank you Council Dale for
supplementary thank you chair I'm very
happy to sit down with councilor Barker
and talk through the issue of School
meals but if the very future of an
important service like School catering
is under threat and it's incumbent upon
us to take difficult decisions to keep
it going and despite all the noise that
I've heard from labor I've seen
absolutely no viable Alternatives being
put forward for how they would deal with
the issue and what else they'd cut in
order to keep prices artificially low
and that's a neat segue back into the
topic that we have at hand here which is
the district council's response uh to uh
please Council Dale yes yes uh yes yeah
all I've heard so far is uh is not a lot
of New Alternatives at all
um can can you really demonstrate to me
that you are actually going to deliver
further focus on cost of living having
made it a key plank of your election
campaign What specifically you're
actually going to do over and above what
the district council was already doing
thank you chair Council Market to reply
it's a tricky one that Alex to be honest
I mean we're a district council
a lot of this it's way above what we can
do as a district council we can sign
both people to various uh
different authorities different helps
and different things it it's all down to
Department of work and pensions uh what
different benefits they get it's all
there's lots and lots of issues we we
are a small Cog in a very big wheel and
we we are and I've acknowledged what
what you did prior were good you know
signposting people to to where they
could get the help and all that other
stuff but we we are committed
to carry on with what you've did and
hopefully uh carry on and help as many
people as we can through this
crisis I suppose uh and I can't say no
more than that
thank you question E from councilor
William Jones so taken as read to
councilor Pickering so Council Pickering
to reply please
thank you thank you chair
um we can see um yet again another claim
to a commitment from the previous
Authority from the previous
administration
um without actually doing anything about
it Hollow words really um that sound
good with no action
um we've got a questionnaire that asks
about commitment to spd's well
supplementary uh planning documents are
attached to the local plan to give more
detail uh further detail to actions
within that local plan
um and um I can offer further um
further guidance on development and
specific sites
if there were really a commitment
hasn't
um but we will be updating that the
local development scheme later this year
to outline the timetable and stages of
that review process
um in the council plan we've committed
to encouraging sustainable places to
build and acquire a sustainable and
affordable homes and we'll be reviewing
the council's climate change strategy
Council Jones for your supplementary
please
thank you councilor Pickering um just
one quick question we haven't got much
time
due to the onerous requirements
associated with post-construction
installation of heat pumps and charging
points does the council intend to insist
on developers future proofing the new
build construction so that future
modifications can be accommodated at
least cost and disruption to the
household this is particularly important
in terms of affordable housing
construction because the sort of tenants
who take those properties up will not
have the funds and the means for the
extensive modification
thank you thank you Council Pickering to
reply thank you yes well as I said we've
got that commitment in the council plan
um and will ensure climate change
adaptation is the key consideration in
the design process with further guidance
for new build refurbishment and
extension of both dwellings and
commercial buildings and there is
reference in there to um electric uh
charging points that will be publicly
available
thank you that brings the end to a
section on procedural 9.2 for questions
from members and just to reiterate that
today a precedent has not been started
for exceeding 15 minutes it was just
today's leeway but from now on
the 15 minutes will be adhered to
item 13 to consider any motions for
members under procedure rule number 10
so we've got motion a proposed by
councilor Shipman
thank you chair um I would like to
propose this motion today which is to
make use of the new powers that are
coming in as of next April to increase
council tax on um empty homes in the
district we've got a rising number of
empty owns in the district there's one
in 66 homes that are currently not
available to local people
um I know the council has unfortunately
had a lack of Staff in this department
to to keep on top of the issue that's
getting worse but I think it's time we
now start looking at and using all of
the powers that are available
particularly this one that's um coming
into Force next year so that we can
start addressing the rising number of
mtms that we have in this District so
that houses can be provided to people to
get on the housing ladder thank you
chair if you have a second there Council
Hancock
thank you so open to the council for
debate so Council Barker
thank you Jared uh yeah thanks for the
question uh well I reckon we've beat you
to it to be honest Ross uh we recognize
this Challenge from a while ago uh about
we empty homes the leadership has
already agreed to review the council tax
premium discussion the policy which is
looking at you can charge extra council
tax for if a place has been empty for a
long uh and the intention for a security
committee which will probably be
communities to reveal this in the Autumn
and then it's come back to cabinet for
approval uh so we are well on with this
uh fully agree you know all your
sentiments in the in the thing but at
this point there's no reason to to agree
to that motion where we're not going to
support that because we're already doing
it thank you
kid Council Dale
yeah thank you chair
um that that's that's welcome to hear
that it's already going to be uh
considered as a uh as a scrutiny topic I
think we broadly support uh the sort of
thrust of the motion the need of uh
needs to do more to bring back empty
properties back into use uh and that
includes obviously exploring the new
council tax Powers I think the caveat
and the strong feeling from our group
were though was that there needs to be
the carrot as well as the stick
um you know we have had the Eon scheme
in in the past which has been very
successful so more schemes like that
would be very useful
um it is a significant issue for the
district but it's not nearly as
significant as it is in other areas and
I think the one thing that we would also
say is we have to be mindful of the
impact on the tourist industry around
second properties you know we all agree
that tourism is hugely important to the
Northeast Derbyshire I'm not saying that
should preclude action but we should
take that into account in a thorough way
as part of a scrutiny review so I think
I was going to suggest an amendment to
the motion uh to delete some of those
Powers but I mean as it's going to go to
scrutiny anyway I think would be happy
to uh to to vote against I think on that
basis
um and I think as part of that scrutiny
review I'd really request that we go
through some of those the ramifications
you know all of the unintended
consequences we just need to be really
mindful of those I think
any other comments
councilor Hancock you wish to exercise
your right now
excuse me thank you chair yeah I mean
just to pick up on councilor Dale's
point I think the key part is long-term
empty properties and I know just mention
second homes
um in terms of both members who have
spoken the uh actual motion is to take
it to scrutiny anyway so voting against
it you're actually voting against your
own policy so I'm really not clear where
your your basis is on there so logic
says you will be supporting it
Council shipment to uh
reply
if if I may just um use the words of
counselor Pickering it's all women could
have an empty promises but the whole
point is that we adopt motions that back
up those alleged promises and the work
that's already going on I find it's such
a bizarre argument to say well we're
gonna do it in Autumn but we can't
support emotion that kind of sets that
in stone now
it just seems really Petty if I'm honest
with you and I thought we were being
very collaborative open and transparent
with each other
thank you so uh motion a then proposed
by Council Shipman and seconded by
councilor Hancock all those in favor of
the motion
all those against
any abstentions
and the motion is lost
so motion B proposed by councilor
Hancock
thank you chair I'm not gonna sit and
Waffle all the way through this
and keep it to a decent length
um yeah obviously I mean we're all
conscious that one of our our greatest
expenditures in the in the district goes
on the Leisure centers we've seen what's
happened just over the Border in
Chesterfield Borough obviously we don't
want that occurring here so it is what I
think is a very common sense approach
um to try and reduce our expenditure on
those without impacting on any services
that we deliver at all so on that basis
then move it to council do we have a
second here Council Shipman
um I'll reserve my right speech
okay so uh I'll go to council Dale first
then Council Barker Council Dale
thank you chair I think with this motion
from our perspective it seems quite out
of date
um doesn't really reflect the current
position I'm concerned about the degree
to which it's scaremongering certainly
when we were in office we had absolutely
no intention to shut or reduce any
Ledger provision before me and if
anything actually we put it in our
Manifesto that we wanted to expand
Leisure provision further out into the
community so that it wasn't uh solely
just based on buildings bricks and
mortar we wanted it to go out further
and obviously protect
um the Leisure centers that we do have
um I mean it's nice to see in the motion
the reference to killer Marsh
particularly when the the lib Dems voted
against uh I was taking kilimash into uh
into the fold we see no budgetary reason
why the new Administration should uh cut
Leisure at all and no reason why this
motion or the lib Dems putting it
Forward should be scaring people over
this uh and I think it's worrying to
even be in a situation where you're
threatening the future of Leisure
Services in the district given that so
successful
we know that Leisure isn't in the etiis
because the government has opened up a
special uh fund extreme specifically for
leisure and I also think the motion
fails to take into account the huge
investment that Northeast Derbyshire has
had from the government and the council
in recent years we've obviously had 1.5
million or close to 1.5 million towards
drumfield uh decarbonisation about a
million pounds towards eckington
decarbonization we've had over seven
million pounds from the government by
the town deal towards the rebuilding of
Charlie Park in Clay Cross with a
million pounds specifically allocated
towards making it as energy efficient
and green as possible I think so I think
from my perspective I want to propose an
amendment to the motion to to take
account of those those aspects and the
fact that actually I think we want to
resolve to welcome that investment and
actually commit as a council to to
keeping our Leisure centers open and
fully functional moving forward so I've
got a paper copy of the amendment if
that's useful got me down that Ram to
I've only got 10 but uh
I can handle you around times are hard
it's not my home printer off right here
amendments are in bold I think
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah
if we're going to do that we've all got
our tablet turns why don't you send
email
to go out during
the virus
just before we go any further
um I think
I think I need to ask Mrs Sternberg to
respond about whether the amendment is
actually negating the original motion
thank you chair yes I think it does
what was that count today
so is that withdrawn counter Dale
folks the only other way around it I
think you know I don't think so
apart from nice try
nice guy
did you want to continue saying anything
else
you still have a bit of time left I
think on that basis we'll vote against
the motion then I think it completely
fails to account as I say the huge
amount of investment we've already had I
don't like motions that scare Monger
around uh around Leisure centers being
cut and I think we shouldn't we
shouldn't be supporting that so I think
I'd prefer to see a motion here that
committed uh to Future Leisure and
therefore we'll vote against chair thank
you
so we're staying on this current uh
motion B so are there any other comments
councilor Barker yeah yeah thanks for
that uh I'm pleased that decision made
our comeback trying to Spot the
Difference here doing my own
uh but yeah that I think that that's
fair uh
I get I get your message but I don't
think that personally it's scare my room
we're happy to support this see it it it
does set out that to Northeast Darwish
is doing a good job with Leisure we
accept that
uh I think the the emphasis is actually
trying to
Lobby government to to book Leisure
centers to give Leisure centers a bit
more money uh because we're not too bad
I know we've submitted a bid to sport
England we're not very hopeful again any
uh any money from them because uh we're
not in the position where we might close
any swimming pools whereas other
authorities are so it is a general thing
and I can get why you won't support it
because we're going to write to Lee
Rowley and uh the Prime Minister but I'm
not confident that'll make any
difference but we will do that so we're
happy to support this motion as it
stands thank you
any other comments
going back
yes yes counselor
no council Shipman you second did you
want to speak now yeah it was just just
really on the point that I know cancer
deals talking about something completely
different which is the capital
investment the district's had and that's
obviously fantastic for our areas but
this is talking about the day-to-day
running costs of the Leisure centers and
that's why we need to address it
um because it's not just an empty you
know barrel of money that we can keep
going from they are our biggest expenses
as a district and it's something that
needs addressing so that's why the
motion's put forward and I'd like to
thank councilor Barker for supporting
this motion as well
and back to you councilor Hancock for
writer reply
thank you and yeah councilor Barker's
got the gist exactly in terms of what
the intern the intention of the motion
is so uh thank you there I'll just pass
comment on Alex's uh attempt at wit with
regard to killer Marsh yeah we did
oppose they're being taken in but we're
also realistic that's what we've got we
deal we play with the hand we dealt
um no one's scaremongering at all we
know that these things are an issue
we've seen in the Derbyshire times we
know what a great effort Northeast
Derbyshire has done and we want to make
sure that we carry on doing it so we
look at every Avenue possible and that's
the spirit of the motion so thank you to
those members who will support
thank you so you've got motion B before
you proposed by councilor Hancock
seconded by Council Shipman all those in
favor of the motion
all those against
any abstentions
then the motion is carried thank you so
we moved to motion C proposed by
councilor windley
thank you chair
the child the tragedy of the child in
Rochdale highlighted for us all how
important it is that dampened black mold
needs to be addressed as soon as
possible
I know that patients in my GP practice
now include the question have you any
damp or mold in your home so the GPS are
obviously trying to keep track on this
as well
and it it does highlight how serious
this problem can become
so as we move towards winter and I just
wondered if at some point we could have
a report
um to bring to council just to see how
um
changes and and tracks are being made on
this problem in the homes around
Derbyshire thank you
thank you council windley do you have a
second year for that
I'll second that chair
um I will I will um brief at this time I
think it is important and I know one
thing it makes reference to is there's a
culture of blaming tenants and of course
as we've had through various of the
questions they've just gone we are going
through a cost of living crisis and
people who perhaps could buy equipment
that would have helped previously or
they could have run dehumidifiers it's
not an option open to
um we should take it Forward on that
basis so now we're debating motion C
counter Durant
be good thank you thank you chair uh so
thank you to councilor windley for
raising this
um black mold a horrible thing and the
death of awab ishak uh is an awful thing
to have read uh I'm broadly in favor of
the themes of this if I'm perfectly
honest are the concern I have
um having dealt with mold is that with
the new way of working with the new
council is that housing are these kind
of scrutinies come under the communities
committee uh
would this not be worth being part of
the community which I compliment
councilor windley's passion because she
is also a member of the communities
committee
um so I just think it should be going
there
on moving forward from there
come on
I'm just before we bring you in Council
Market didn't you with Council windy if
you accepted that it should be
going back to communities
right okay right got it
you accept it so thank you so that
friendly amendment is accepted that it
goes before a community scrutiny
committee
thank you Council Barker yeah I got that
in my my bit to actually amend the the
things in this in this motion uh I think
I'll I'll say whatever we're going to
say is that uh well we've got the
sentiments of the Emulsion we fully uh
we fully get that but I think it's worth
noting that that we as a council and
rignal they're already committed to
doing as much as we can with this and we
refer to it in the council plan that in
Partnership we're equal homes we're
going to deliver social housing that
meets consumer standards for social
housing uh and so we will ensure all
Council homes are well maintained to try
and meet the health needs of tenants
which is easier said than done in some
cases because of their substandard
nature of Summer houses but having said
that we will work to do to monitor the
situation in private rented sector and
the more Powers we have over that sector
the better
uh we did feel uh that it is an attempt
to council policy by the back door so
with that in mind we we wanted to change
the last paragraph as well for any
children report to be taken back to
cabinet uh so changing the service
excuse me to communities because as far
as I know that's on your radar already
looking at all this uh so can I move
the amendment then all it does is
changes
services to community and dangers
Council to cabinet
uh
point of order are you happy to
say I'll second that because I didn't
say there was a specific Amendment
right so that we
what's the point of order Council
shipment well well the new the new um
constitutional word in it is it needs to
go to a scrutiny and go to cabinet so
therefore by default and I think that's
what that's what they're saying well
it's a sink and and it's the same
cabinet it's said for it to go to uh
yeah
scrutiny and cabinet that's what the
wording needs to be but councilor
Barker's saying just cabinet
Council Mark was very clear he said
scrutiny and cabinet
yeah so hopefully that's clear yeah okay
right so we're now debating the
amendment unless uh
councilor Hancock
thanks chair um I think our key Point
here because yeah I absolutely agree
with what's just been said about it
going to scrutiny and to Cabinet but I
think the key point is we wanted to come
back to council we want to proper report
on it so I'm not happy to accept the
amendment on that basis so we're
debating the amendment then so it's not
accepted as a friendly Amendment so um
so the amendment is that it would go
before a scrutiny committee and to
cabinet so that's been proposed by
councilor Barker and seconded by Council
Durant so it's debate on the amendment
Council Cupid
thank you I think likewise um I've no
problem with it going to the uh
Community scrutiny committee but I think
it would be useful for it to come back
to council as we've all discussed and I
think we all agree this is a serious
issue it is a massive issue for Rick
nordundo from from when we were in
administration so I don't know whether
you can amend your Amendment
um councilor but even just presumably to
say if uh you know it's considered by
cabinet in terms of actions but a report
comes back or a presentation to council
I think we'd be more willing to to
support it on that basis
okay
[Music]
what we don't want to do is set to
precedent I think we've had this debate
in past about setting policy at the
council meeting before it's gone through
scrutiny and all the processes
uh
I think I think we can personally I
think we can live without if it goes to
Cabinet first
and then so we don't want it directly
coming straight back to council without
going through all the due processes what
what we're trying to say in in that
amendment I think that is that
acceptable uh well I'm going to put it
back to councilor Hancock Council winley
because it feels like we're going around
in circles now we've got a friendly
amendment to a friendly amendment to a
friendly amendment to it I'm not so sure
it's friendly anymore
so um so are we saying now that it's all
right for it to go to scrutiny cabinet
and then back to council for a report
and information
can I can I say as a presentation to
council presentation right so you're
saying presentations
are you accepting that councilwin Lee
right so that is it
are we clear so far so we're now we've
now accepted the council winding Council
Hancock have accepted the friendly
amendments thank you Council Cupid so
what we're now saying is motion C with
the amendment that it would go before
scrutiny committee
then to Cabinet yeah and then it would
come for presentation here at full
Council
counselor
yes the community spiritually yes just
to be clear thank you yeah
well no why don't you've sorted it
are we all happy with that so far right
so that is what we're debating now so
any other comments or questions about
that
if not I'm going to ask councilor
windley to reply
thank you chair yeah I'm happy for that
that's in the last paragraph I think
that's a report to come back here when
all you know the rounds type of thing
and I know it's briefly being touched on
in the community scrutin is because I
asked about black mold there as well and
some of the questions I asked were
answered there so it'd be good to see a
full report thank you thank you Council
windley so just to be ultra clear on
motion C so it's going to go to
communities scrutiny then cabinet full
Council for presentation so
the rest of the motion as is
all those in favor
any against
any abstentions
emotion C with its Amendment to the
amendment amendment has been approved
thank you
thank you motion d
I thought you Council Cupid
thank you
um I think this motion has become more
topical since I submitted it I have not
checked the news today but it was
actually motivated by local factors and
discussions uh namely the actions of
some other local councils in Derbyshire
and concerns raised with me by residents
and businesses locally to start off I
want to be really clear as this motion
sets out at the start that I'm not in
any way distracting from the challenges
we face on climate change or the need to
take urgent action however the process
with which this motion seeks to condemn
do distract from the climate emergency
in my view whilst they have to date been
focused on local cities people have
expressed a concern to me that they
could cause disruption in our local area
so I just want this Council to be clear
in setting out that we don't support
those actions we absolutely should be
working together and these protests feel
to me like we're not as well as having
costs to tourism the economy and public
order which could be better spent on
reducing carbon emissions
this point applies equally to the second
part of the motion focused on car usage
and in our rural District I would hope
this is something all members can get
behind
alongside the national Euless debate
I've been particularly concerned by
proposals in nearby Derbyshire Dales to
try to introduce the charging Zone in a
local town center and because of this
and the recent Sheffield Clean Air Zone
I've had lots of residents contact me to
express concern this could be introduced
in Northeast Derbyshire and I know many
of my group members have had similar
issues raised likewise to focus on Clay
Cross as my most local Town Center it's
been rumored to me that charges to car
Parks could be introduced and I hope
we're all all against that and so an
access to car parking remains a massive
issue raised with me by residence shops
and visitors I know people who've been
put off trying to park or who spend ages
idling their vehicle trying to find the
right way into local car parks in Clay
Cross to check the town deal is a chance
to improve some of this and with
something our Administration was
committed to but I've been concerned by
some recent comments so I hope we can
all support this notion to demonstrate
to our communities we will continue that
work
whilst we absolutely should support
alternative means of travel buses
cycling and walking cars and hopefully
crucially electric vehicles remain a
Lifeline for many in this rural area and
so we should not be banning or
restricting cars or parking in my view
especially in our town centers to do so
to me just moves traffic elsewhere and
it would also be the death in all of our
high streets when encouraging local
Journeys shopping and economies should
actually be a positive small step for
our environment
equally access to car parking remains an
issue for many of our rural local
Villages and on our housing Estates it
can be the cause of neighborly disputes
sometimes it can be dangerous if
emergency vehicles or Services can't get
access and it can make residents feel
isolated if they don't go out if they
don't if they'll have a space when
they'll come back I know it's a big
issue which can't be tackled overnight
I'm concerned that the new
Administration has paused the previous
strategy that we had so I hope we'll all
support the pleasures in this motion to
restart that and work together on a
cross-party basis to improve car parking
in both our town centers and for
residents and Village businesses in our
in our sort of rural Villages as well
and that's that's it Jeff so happy to
propose that thank you and Council Dale
for seconding happy to Second and
reserve the rights to be later thank you
councildale Council Addington Stringer
oh thank you thank you chair
um I'm relatively new to this Council as
you all know and I'm absolutely amazed
at the amount of political Point scoring
that's been going on so far and with
every other breath them being but we're
working together
um it just amazes me really
this uh motion
um is is outrageous I can't believe
we're actually discussing this this
afternoon
um councilor Dale referred to scare
mongering in the previous motion this is
is absolutely scared of hungry it's
nothing more it's electioneering
actually is what it is off the back of a
general election result
um
I can't see anything positive in this
because people of Northeast Derbyshire
whatsoever it's a totally hypocritical
motion which seeks to praise the last
conservative Administration cover
yourselves in glory for the significant
progress already made
whilst reversing
that at the same time we're in an area
where bus services are already hard to
come by and yet you're looking at
promoting car use across the district
this is fundamentally flawed on every
level and nobody in this room I believe
should be voting for this motion we're
in a climate crisis and this is the last
thing that we should be voting for
it's Point scoring and it's classic
conservative Beyond climate
um it's seeking to cover yourselves in
glory at election time and trying to set
yourselves up
um on the issues that are in the news in
the headlines and I find that really
quite shameful when we're in a serious
crisis
finally I would like to add that if
there are any protests of any nature I
will be there with those people I will
be sat protesting for Action I will not
not let this Council
Isis is fundamental to the future of our
communities and any proposal against
that will be will be fought against
tooth and nail by me and hopefully by
many colleagues in this room so I urge
you all to reject this thank you very
much
thank you Council Barker
all of that
[Laughter]
yeah yeah well sad Frank I think you've
done it there and I apologize for the
political Point scoring well that's what
we do
that's what I do that's it is a this
environment and it sometimes not very
healthy but this is the only opportunity
we get to to make some political points
so I think that's going to continue
hence
my speech
uh I will just it's a bit confusing this
motion to be honest in fact it's that
long-winded authority to come from lib
Dems because it's one it's one it's one
of theirs and
[Laughter]
and we recognize obviously there's a
climate emergency uh and I think that
that's a milk point because I know that
the County Council you you amended a
motion to say it's an email it's uh it's
a class it's not an emergency so what we
will acknowledge the progress that's
made already and continue with them
policies uh and we might not agree with
some of the actions of the groups
mentioned but deny people the right to
uh to demonstrate it's a slippy slope
that I don't think we we should get
involved with that they've obviously got
passionate about their their cause
uh and then they jump on from that to
the car parking issue seems a bit
tenuous uh and I and what I can say is
that we all know the car parking
strategy has proved a lot more
problematic than than we thought when it
first first started just allocating some
money sent fine but then it's a lot more
complicated especially when you're using
HRA that's Council tennis money to
provide car parking for private tenants
like likely we did enough and all that's
another one
and given that way in the process of
reviewing that policy we accept that
more car parking is a good thing and if
we can deal with that and building more
electric charging points and totally
review how we deal with that then that's
a good thing but because of the
complicated nature and and some of the
things what what Frank said uh we're not
going to support this motion
if your counselor Reed
I just want to thank everybody that's uh
had a point of view and to my apologies
councilor Stringer I'm also quite new so
it's it's very much an experience being
here
my understanding of this motion is it's
setting out a commitment from Council
not to make any radical changes at the
moment given yes we are in a crisis yes
we have a cost of living emergency and
as a father of four
um you look at living on the border of
Sheffield going into Sheffield and
having to pay 60 quid per day which
isn't happening yet for private motor
vehicles but in other places it is we
are increasing the cost of living so I
think this motion is more confirming not
denying the the real sort of scenario of
the environment where we live right now
but also setting out to our residents
the commitment to be there to support
their families in a cost of living
crisis that we aren't going to be
suddenly putting in or implementing
changes that is going to cost them out
of their Hip Pocket and actually give a
choice of Transport or feeding their
families so I would urge councilor Baker
and most of my labor colleagues that I
work with on a district Annie
um Paris level would tell you I'm very
much for
a political doing what's right for our
residents and that's what we're here for
first our welfare our primary
responsibility is for the welfare of our
constituents and I don't think uh so I
think that this motion sets out to keep
that at heart and center of what it
actually sets out to be
thank you
Council Pickering
thank
you thank you thank you chair I mean
it's already been said it's difficult to
know where to go with this motion the
three things together are more like a
bit of a rant than anything constructive
to put to this Council
um and uh you know we are in a political
debating chamber and we've got quite a
right to do that
um so and we'll expose some of the
hypocrisy and I can remind people that
at the council meeting on the 26th of
April 2021
um you know this motion starts off by
saying we recognizes a climate emergency
at that meeting
um we proposed a motion to support the
climate emergency and ecology bill
um that would have put a positive action
from this Council undertaking some real
action and every Tory member I think in
that Council chamber on that day voted
against it
so it's difficult for us to know exactly
where they're coming from with the
climate responsibility
um and it seems from this motion if it
fits their conversations with voters or
if it's uh their ideology and it's
climate change and if it doesn't we want
to ignore it
um nationally I think they're following
the national uh Tory commitment to
climate change which is very weak and it
favors the continued use of oil and gas
and we've seen this morning the Prime
Minister committed to issuing hundreds
of licenses in the North Sea
um with a smoke screen of a carbon uh
capture scheme to cover it up
um you know the conservatives have been
responsible for climate damage and fuel
poverty
and of course people want to protest
against that the kids are starving the
cold in their homes without you know
there's damp on the mold on their walls
although this council's more positive
about that
um and the Tories didn't change that
when they had an opportunity to vote on
the private renters bill they opposed a
motion for good quality housing and so
they're responsible for what's being
going off of course people complain and
they want to protest
we've got some protest groups they do
cause some disruption by and large
they're peaceful there have been odd
outbreaks
um and to try either through legislation
in Parliament or to try in this Council
chamber here to suppress people's right
to have their voice and say something
against it is quite wrong for us to do
to try and silence our
um constituents
um
yeah
um the Tories have continued an attack
on
on the the law and traffic neighborhoods
proper public transport Alternative
Energy
[Music]
um and have exacerbated these principles
on lowering their commitment to climate
change ever since David Cameron referred
to it as green crap there's been no
official sustainable commitment to it
nationally or locally and I know you'll
come back and you'll tell us in a minute
or what you think you've done and now
that's come uh benefited this uh
Northeast Derbyshire but I think people
know what the real answers are and they
know what it is locally
um and that's where we are today in this
Council chamber and that's why you're
over there
um you have no place giving us any
lectures on the green agenda you've got
the worst record in Europe uh ever since
your party turned against a positive
green agenda thank you chair
councilor Durand
thank you sorry
um I wasn't going to comment on this but
I feel like I've been forced to by uh I
counselor colleague over there and by uh
Frank uh councilor Stringer
um I'm a father too of twins and I can
tell you having twins is expensive a lot
more expensive than individual children
one at a time at times
um I have to take my kids to the next
Village over
to
uh get them to school because my local
school grassmore is oversubscribed
but I can't take a bus
because the bus is unreliable
equally the pathway going from grassmer
to North Wingfield is terrifyingly small
smaller the width of my shoulders so
it's a bit scary when the bus goes past
me and I think it's going to whack me
walk me upside the head
so my point is this is I just find it a
bit galling to say that we're going to
have the counselors who have raised and
seconded this to be the one that's in
charge of Transport when it's so
unbelievably and ruinously expensive to
take public transport to take your kids
to school
because it's two pounds yeah it's a two
pound cap that's wonderful there's two
pound for one stop it's two pound for
two stops so if you go into school once
one or two stops over congratulations
that's two pounds that's now four pound
that's now eight pound while they have
to pick them up and if you have to uh
get a pass you can't get a basic pass so
it's just calling that this has been
raised
um and this is not supporting green it's
just buzzwords it's not supporting
people in the cost of living crisis I
just wanted to raise as a parent how
disgusting I find this motion thank you
thank you councilor Hancock
foreign
thank you chair um I say this is one of
the few members here that don't actually
drive and so public transport in our and
yeah this is a really haphazard motion
to be honest there's there's some things
in it that I do think are I would
support like maximizing EV charging and
improving the car parking strategy both
of which are an issue but it's small
parts of a hole that really doesn't work
for me
um we should be calling on improved
um public transport I mean I live in
Topton it's actually quicker to walk to
Clay Crossland to get the bus because
the bus detours all around homegate and
everywhere else it's 10 minutes longer
to get the bus than it is to to walk but
it is a big District we have got
problems we need to look at focusing on
that this in itself to me I don't know I
mean
as it stands up being client to vote
against it but I think I probably say to
counselors Cupid endailed or they want
to withdraw it and bring it back as a
better a better Motion in future rather
than have it fall
um and not have the opportunity to bring
you back for six months but um yeah as
it stands I think there's a lot more
that needs to do counts the read I think
made a very valid point in his speech
about the cost of living crisis but this
doesn't even address that so he's
supposed to read between the lines on
that rather than being a direct motive
to it
um so yeah I think there's there's good
parts but on the whole
that it it doesn't work and and I
couldn't vote for the whole just for the
sake of two things that's in it thank
you Council Shipman thank you chair
um yeah as has been mentioned it's it's
like the conservative group have just
got a bowl of spaghetti and from it at
the water and wants to throw it at all
and see what sticks
um it's just all over the place it
really is all over the place you've got
on one hand trying to stop people using
their Democratic right to protest on
issues that matter to them which is
their right and if it falls outside of
the law or the police pick that up so I
don't know why the district council is
discussing that
um and just to pick up on some other
points about particularly and I I had to
laugh when I saw the um about the money
for car parking and there's councilor
Barker will know councilor Thacker will
know and various other people in the
former audit committee it's an issue we
debated I think it was every meeting for
about two years because there was this
Potter money
but the money was being spent wherever
the leader wanted it to there were no
strategy behind it it was is it an
unstone Ward or not and unfortunately
areas like topton's Clay Cross
wingworths sherlands they all got left
out of that debate and to this day we
are still waiting for additional car
parking and I think that introduced what
three years ago
um so there's a you know it was funny to
be fair
um and councilor Durant storm of Thunder
because the fact that public transport
is dire in Northeast Derbyshire first of
all the conservatives that are running
the County Council pulled funding in
2020 I think it was for buses and only
because of some central government
funding which has come back it's like
Robin Peter to pay Paul that they're now
looking at bringing bringing back
additional Services well the the
conservatives at canned council could
look at public transport and make it
better for the likes of council Durham
that's trying to get his kids to school
myself is trying to you know go and
visit friends and family in other parts
in office Derbyshire we've got no choice
but to use cars at the moment because
public transport is so bad and there's
only one group in this Castle chamber
that's responsible for that I counter
level it's not labor it's not that I've
done it's not the greens it's the
conservatives
so I'll be voting against this chair
yeah
[Laughter]
so uh
any other any other comments counselor
Burkin
thank you chair just just very briefly
um uh we had spaghetti last night uh
Russ so I can see where you're going I
didn't spill it over the wall but nearly
enough I think there's a danger in this
motion it starts off uh end of the first
paragraph that would condemn the
disruptive action of organizations
that's a very very very very dangerous
line to go down uh unfortunately the
people who are supporting such ideas as
a condemn action
never appreciate what support they have
had by other people making actions
taking a fight for them on their behalf
and I think that's something that's lost
completely in our society today and it's
very important that we maintain that all
right you're not going to get to uh
down the road you're not going to be
able to buy this or that for some small
proportionate time but it is really
really very limited the the disruption
that you get it's blown out of all well
proportion by the media because there's
nothing else to go at
I think at the same time so it's missing
the point I think that's missing the
point I think at the same time the three
pledges that we've got there they're
each missing the point as well because
there are more important things to do
about car usage do we need to have car
usage shouldn't we get better supporters
have been said by colleagues from from
buses or whatever it might be but just
to say we will keep keep car usage
because we need to have better park car
parking and better electric vehicles
that's not going to be a solution
electric vehicles is about five or six
times as heavy as ordinary ones so we
think the county councilors are not
doing very well with the potholes at the
moment uh understand the electric
vehicles are going to make bridges are
going to be falling down 10 20 times
earlier than they would normally have
done so I think it's it's um it's trying
to gloss over things and it's and it's
hiding a lot of points which are very
very important to the rest of us and
therefore I think
um if only for the first bit which isn't
one of the pledges I ban in protest that
everybody should be voting about against
that we've all benefited from somebody
else's process interested on our behalf
and you should never forget that thank
you chair thank you
[Applause]
I think that's everyone so I'm going to
come back to council Dale
thank you chair I've quite enjoyed that
debate I think I've made a mental note
to put forward or to collectively put
forward more Motions like this to be
honest
um I mean on the first point around
protest no one is suggesting that people
shouldn't have the right to peacefully
protest and that's not what this motion
says it's condemning the disruptive
actions of those two organizations and I
think you know when you're hearing about
people who are unable to get to dying
relatives because there's a motor
blockade on the M1 or whatever
um you know I think that there is there
is reason to condemn those actions and I
think it's important that we take that
stand and I think if you ask if you did
a poll of most people the Northeast
diversary the vast majority would say
that they don't support the actions of
people who want to stop them from
getting on with their day-to-day lives
you know we talk about freedom and
liberty well there's freedom to do
something but there's also freedom from
something and I think it's important
that we uh that we support residents and
make them aware that we do support them
and getting on with their day-to-day
lives
um interesting that councilor Abington
will be first on the on the on the
protest March made a note of that and
I'm sure he's residents in wingoweth
will be pleased to hear that as well
um just on the HR the usage of the HRA
uh I mean certainly in apple they're
very happy with it and it's done very
well and it's actually really supportive
so the idea that it's only in apple
though is is a nonsense I think the list
included renish or the original list of
the first year of renishaw there was
some in grassmore and North Wingfield I
think uh there's one in Ross's Ward as
well a trial program in Ross's world as
well so I'm surprised that that's that's
coming back I think the fundamental fact
was we recognized there were
shortcomings of that scheme my own
regret is that we were we didn't push on
with it as quick as as we should have
and we had challenges in terms of
capacity in the engineering team and we
should have pushed on more but the key
factor for me was that that was an issue
that was ignored for the past 30 years
as far as I can see I have no evidence
that the previous labor administration's
ever addressed car parking in our
Estates and no surprise to anyone people
have more and more cars and have had
more and more cars over the past few
decades so we have more of a problem and
this idea that it's solely about
benefiting private homeowners that's not
true it was only available in areas
where the majority of householders were
uh tenants and I think the difference is
this our Administration was willing to
do something about it and sadly it
sounds like that's under review now so
it probably won't happen
um
I think that's all I want to say and
I'll I'll hand over them
thank you councilor cubit2 respond
okay um
it's disappointing if I'm honest
particularly from from some of the labor
members at the language that is once
again used of I'm disgusting just
because you don't agree with me again
that used to come up when we were in
administration and I think that it sets
a nasty tone to the debate I I just
because I disagree with you I have no
reason to call you disgusting so I just
wanted to to note
um that that it was disappointing as
councilor Dale says and as I've said in
my opening speech I was really clear
that I'm not denying climate change I'm
not denying the right to process you
know fully support that it was the
disruptive nature of the protests that
this motion was seeking to to highlight
and to to raise concern against and then
as the second sort of final closing
Point again I'm pretty disappointed that
the debate has taken the sense of
focusing on public transport and in
councilor pickering's case starving
children that actually this debate
wasn't I recognized in my opening speech
that you know we all we should encourage
public transport and we should do
everything we can and that's certainly
something we're doing it can T but this
debate was about our town centers and
car usage and about the car parking
strategy and again I was a little bit
disappointed in I think it was councilor
Barker's comments that the car parking
strategy is a bit complicated and
problematic so therefore let's not do it
you know that was sort of the
implication so it was it's sort of like
that's why this professional
constructive on it let's work together
let's find a way forward on it and on
improving Town Center car parking so a
little bit disappointed at the the way
that the the debate has gone because it
was a constructive motion but uh yeah
happy to push the vote and can I just
ask for a recorded vote as well please
sure
I've got three people then uh asking for
it to be a recorded vote so this is for
motion D proposed by Council Cupid
second by councilor Dale so we are going
to move to a recorded vote so um your
name will be called so you need to say
whether you are four against or abstain
councilor winley
Council weatherall
Council Welton
Council Thacker cool cancer Stone
councilor Spooner
councilor Christine Smith
councilor Caroline Smith
councilor Skinner
Council Shipman against Council Rouse
Council Rowe
Council Reed well Council Pickering
against councilor Peterson
councilor Morley Mickey Morley
Council Jeff Morley yes Council Liggett
councilor Tony Lacy
councilor Carol Lacy
councilor Kerry against Council William
Jones
Council Pam Jones
councilor Higgin
Council hartshorn
councilor Hancock
counselor gar
thank you yeah sorry councilor Foster
Council Fletcher
councilor Elliott
councilman Durant cancer Dayton
Council Dale
cancer Cupid
Council Cornwall against councilor
Cooper
Council Clough or councilor Clegg
councilor Cheatham
Council Burkin councilor Beach
Council Baxter
councilor Barry I guess
Council Barker again councilor Baker
and councilor adlington Stringer
proudly against
there's no extra points
against
so the vote is 14 votes four
and 32 votes against so the motion is
lost it's just caused a walk out
[Laughter]
pushing is
live I think the opposite of the word
motion there
is this a good time to remind people
about the smt car wash
[Laughter]
it's not we do bicycles as well
apparently
um anyway so we're going to motion a
um to you councilor Dale
thank you chair I'll I'll keep this as
brief as I can recognizing that we've
been on for a while now
um I think the point I'd wish to make is
that no sooner are the dust settled on
the recent local election campaign than
the labor party leader has very
cynically come out with some concerning
statements on the green belt in relation
to relaxing Greenbelt planning
restrictions and tasking all new labor
Council Leaders with reviewing
development policies to provide more
housing
also seeking to introduce top-down or
reintroduce top-down mandatory housing
targets which were scrapped in 2010 or
11 I believe by the coalition government
um councilor Barker knows very well that
I've written to him and I'm very
grateful for his reply
um but I think you know in the interest
of being open and transparent I didn't
really feel like I felt particularly
enlightened by the reply and what the
local labor party's view of the
Greenbelt is and how they intend to
review those local planning policies and
I don't think I think residents deserve
to be able to hear that from the horse's
mouth as it were in terms of what steps
are going to be taken in relation to
agreement and whether the green belt is
safe so as I say we keep being reminded
about being an open and transparent
Council I'd urge the leadership of the
council to take this opportunity to
spell out exactly what they have in
store for the green belt and join us in
opposing any relaxation of it by
supporting this motion
Council Cupid to second
yes chair happy to Second and reserve
the right to speak thank you
so councilor Barker
I'm a horse now I'm a guy key
again thanks for this motion and uh I
think first I can pick up uh from this
motion and uh and the letter that you
sent me after about two days
and later thank you for that uh is that
you obviously think here storm is going
to be next prime minister
so
we're still worried about what he was
saying else
uh I've also listened to closer to what
to what's been said I went to the LJ
conference as I said I listened to Angel
Arena uh and I've got a recording rare
speech on here if you want to listen
from the horse's mouth I'm sure you
won't uh but uh
I think what I've picked up from that is
that the labor part and I've I've read
what guest armor said and all that that
you'll refer to in your letter that the
labor party is committed to building
more houses that that's that's true uh
given that the Tories had failed to meet
the the house building targets that that
we should have been building over the
last 12 years
uh and Andrew Lorena did make it clear
that it's not about it at the expense of
destroying the green belt I cannot I can
on every occasion I think Lisa nandy
said it as well what's been said is the
certain bits of of land like garage
plots car parks and rubbish tips that
are dairy leaked and have been Dairy
leaked for ages that happened to be in
the green belt uh and it seems obvious
we've got to consider developing them
and and the Avail that said on several
occasions
I don't know the the reveal the local
plan which could have started 18 months
ago like Steve says uh but but for for
obvious reasons that wasn't uh
so we will start that review uh and I'm
sure there'll be plenty of opportunity
for communities to get involved uh and
I'm sure You'll Play Your Part in
ensuring residents will be encouraged to
take that take part in that process and
again I can see what you're doing it's a
bit like
Frank said earlier I know you're going
to keep on on with this now until
election but it it is just political
Point scoring to try and make the point
and scare among the people that we're
that the labor party is going to build
on the green belt and we're not
that is not what that's all about we've
got to get ours numbers up but we've got
to do it in the in the correct manner
we've got Bill the right homes in the
right places and that's what we're
committed to thank you Council Hancock
thank you chair um well I shouldn't use
the exact words I use but I must admit I
was surprised that this motion actually
even appeared on the agenda because it's
all very speculative it's it's not based
in any kind of fact at all it's all
hypotheticals what if this happens what
if that happens we really don't know
um I mean I fully support any motion
that puts decisions in local hands
and I think hopefully we will have that
but we don't even know what what
decisions any future government would
take what political color that that
government would take so I think um kind
of preempting that is is foolish
um
I I don't support the the motion purely
on the fact that it is hypothetical
um but we as I say we fully agree that
it should be decisions that are taken at
local level
um
I'm wary about government setting
targets but if if local councils aren't
following because I'm an art meeting
demand then then that perhaps needs to
be done but again everything needs to be
put in the hands of local people where
it can but this motion
if we scrap the first half and said
let's get on with the next local plan
then I'd be fully behind it but but it
doesn't and I am also going to add we've
seen just this last week the fact that
the local plan isn't worth the paper
it's written on with an appeal that we
actually successfully defended when we
didn't have one that's now been um
that's now been put through now that we
do have one and we're building in the
settlement development limit between
Topton and wingler so I think we've also
got a question what the purpose of the
local plan is because it ain't being
adopted by uh by planning inspectorate
thank you any other comments or
questions counselor Foster then Council
Addington Stringer and Council weather
thank you chair
um I know councils have said the the
they were playing politics with this and
we vote for Council Hancock talk of
hypothetical uh situations but this is
this is a fairly simple one uh this uh
it resolves to protect the green belt
and greenfields in any future local plan
review and it asks uh that residents be
kept fully informed it doesn't last much
more than that there's nothing else this
is fairly simple this
um so I'm very happy to support this and
I think rather than just going back all
over the place and thinking of what
might have been said or what's right
behind it I'd say just you know read the
motion and see what it is it's there to
protect the green belt and know more
than that and it's a subject which is
really close to my heart so I'm more
than happy to support this chair thank
you Stringer
thank you as someone who's naturally
inclined to protecting the green belt
you might be surprised here that I'm not
going to be supporting this motion and
I'm so disappointed I'm so disappointed
that so quickly after having just said
what I've just said about the motion
before which
seemed to want to stop protest that
we're now having another one which the
first half is I was reading a biography
about Kia starmer I'm really unsure why
this is coming to council
um it doesn't set out anything practical
really it's just a political Point
scoring game and that is all that
conservatives seem to be
um able to do at this moment
um in echoing what cancer Hancock has
said I would absolutely support local
decisions being made by local people and
protecting green spaces wherever
possible of course but this is purely
hypothetical and purely political Point
scoring and I think conservative should
go and look long and hard in the mirror
before they bring in all the motion to
council
so whether all
thank you yes uh chair just wanted to
put a marker down really because
representing a very very rural community
as I do it was a bit of a dismay and
surprise to learn that none of it is
covered by Greenbelt legislation and I
just want to put that marker down it's
something that I'd like to pursue and
think about in the future for the
communities of ashover
student council Shipman
thank you chair um I wonder if councilor
Foster will understand this simple
statement in that when the conservatives
are in Administration in 2021 when the
local plan was approved
that Administration decided to take
parts of the green belt out so it could
be built on as part of the local plan
so yes your motion may be very simple
but I think it's very hypocritical and
contradictory of what your
Administration did only two years ago
um the problem we've got with it and
this with the whole Greenbelt debate is
that it gets people to go we want to
build on Greenbelt we don't want to
build on Greenbelt and in fact if you go
out and speak to people in community the
bits of land that they want to protect
at the green belt and Greenfield
directly adjacent to those existing
settlements
they would be open to building new
settlements away from the existing ones
to meet that housing need but what do we
end up with this Punch and Judy debate
where it's well I don't want to build a
green Bill well no you want to build on
Greenbelt that's not helpful this
Council has got to keep building houses
into the future this current local plan
is going to expire at some point and
we're going to be having another debate
about where the next lot of houses go so
if you keep saying we want to protect
this area we want to protect that area
forever you never build any houses in
fact that's why we've seen such a high
high supply of houses being built in
around clay Crossing in my ward in
wingworth the you're just going to
concentrate them to one specific area so
if you're not going to build currently
if you adopted this policy as it's
written today
you would literally be only building on
garage sites that are available well we
all know when anybody with at least one
brain cell knows that you can't meet
that the housing need just building on
the existing Brownfield sites and I'm
sure the conservatives when the
administration knew this so I don't know
why they propose an emotion which would
essentially
hamstrung any future Administration on
this motion that would be adopted today
so I really can't support this motion
and I don't even understand why they're
wasting our time today debating it
also Pickering
thank you chair
um I mean I think the only really simple
thing about this motion uh from the
conservatives is it's more
scaremongering
um they've picked sound bites out of uh
various news items and statements that's
been made and turned them into
hypothetical scare mongering I don't
know whether this is just part of their
political lobbying or what but we have
got some facts in 2019 you know the
conservative group promised the people a
killer Marsh they protect them from
development in the green belt since then
there's been a massive uh housing
um development that's got planning
permission in killer Marsh and where the
tourists they've ducked and dived the
issue they're away from it they're not
making any comment and they've avoided
The Fallout
um what they could look at quite
positively is that we've got Northeast
Derbyshire District Council a five-year
housing land Supply statement that's
required from the government that
identifies all available building land
for us to use to meet our housing
commitment for the next five years and I
can't see anything in there that's green
built
um so we've got no intentions of at this
moment in time of any developments in
the green belt and we've just um
recently in the process of updating uh
our statement of consultation on
planning how that takes place they can
read that so businesses the public and
everybody else will have their Say in
any future development they're public
documents chair this is just mischievous
scare mongering and I won't be
supporting this motion thank you
any other comments
Council Bluff
thank you chair
um
in relation to kill a marsh
can I just ask where the labor
representatives were when the appeal Was
Heard
conservatives
backed the rage group and were at the
appeal every single day
not one day did labor turn up to that
that appeal
thank you thank you we fought to for
nail
and
to to say that land and it just amazes
me that labor are turning around and
saying that it's our fault
thank you chair thank you and councilor
Carol Lacy
thank you
as a new representative for killer Marsh
West I would just like to refute what
councilor cloth has just said the killer
Marsh people the labor group were always
behind rage and we stood up as and when
we could if we would have had a
neighborhood plan in place we would have
been able to stop all this building but
we didn't have one and the conservatives
are to blame for that
thank you
any other comments
if not I'm going to come back to council
Cupid for your
response a seconder thank you chair um
just just before I like to cancel the
day we're playing in more detail I think
as councilor Foster said this is this is
quite a simple motion you know you'd be
happy to to remove the the sort of
narrative around it but it's quite a
simple motion to protect the green belt
and green fields in future local plans
and to work together uh on you know on
preparing another local plan given that
previously we haven't had a plan for a
decade in Northeast Derbyshire and
that's that's what led to a lot of the
speculative developments that you know
and and I was quite amused by councilor
pickering's comments just now saying
that he's sorted a five-year land Supply
and he sorted a new statement of uh
consultation because that they were the
two two things we did before the
elections in May and and the five-year
land Supply is something that's been in
place for quite a long time and the
five-year land Supply does not protect
you on its own you have to have
up-to-date uh planning policy documents
so yeah just disappointed with the with
the opposition comments today not to
support this because as councilor Foster
says I think it's quite clear thing and
could send a clear reassurance to
Residents that we want to continue
protecting the green belt and green
fields
Adele For Your Right of reply thank you
just taking the points in turn I was
interested to hear from councilor Barker
uh it sounded a bit like secured armor
came out with some comments and then a
load of ministers were wheeled out to
row back on them because they got a bit
fidgety and a bit scared that actually
the comments he'd made weren't that
popular with the general public so not
surprising that Angela Raynor and Lisa
nandy and others have come out and rode
back on that the point about the local
plan review and the fact that we could
have started earlier I don't really
believe what we could and actually most
importantly I don't think we should be
lectured on being slow on the local plan
the last local plan expired in 2011 and
over the seven years that followed the
labor administration had still not got
it to an adoptable standard we then had
to inherit it and try to amend it given
the uh the challenges that we faced in
terms of the green belt but any
lecturing of us about being slow on the
local plan is just absolutely ridiculous
and the result of having a local plan
that was out of date for so many years
is is that we had absolutely wanton
speculated a speculative development all
in the south of the district thousands
of houses approved that we could not
stop because we did not have a local
plan in place now respect um councilor
Hancock's Point around uh the more Road
appeal and it's disappointing that the
inspector has gone against the local
plan there but time and time again we
had appeal after appeal and every single
one of them we lost because we did not
have a local plan and that fundamentally
is Labor's fault because they didn't get
the backside into gear and get it
approved they handed us an absolute car
crash of a problem there were sites
several sites uh promoting development
on the Green Belt I mean councilor
Pickering raises the point around uh
kilimarsh that fight was first put
forward by a labor Administration there
were 860 houses first proposed in
dronfield we worked two the nail we
fought two for nail to get those sites
out as a conservative group we
campaigned alongside resident and we
reduce that down to about 200 in drum
field we got 400 houses out of the local
plan in eckington by councilor Kenyan
effectively being at every single
planning appeal meeting for three weeks
that's how we did it so being lectured
by the labor party around uh approving
sites in the Greenberg is absolutely
verging on ridiculous and I can't even
believe it's been raised to be honest so
I'm happy to move the recommendation or
move the motion to a vote and I'd ask
that there's a recorded vote on this
thank you chair
we've got Council Cooper and councilor
Foster also calling for a recorded vote
so again we go to a roll call of names
so um this is motion e proposed by
Council Dale second to buy Council Cupid
and Mrs Sternberg will uh for your name
so it's either for against or abstain
thank you chair councilor winley
Council weatherall
Council Welton
Stone
cancer Spooner
councilor Christine Smith again
councilor Caroline Smith
cancer Skinner
Council Shipman
Council Rouse
Council Rowe
Council Reed
cats are Pickering against councilor
Peterson okay
councilman Nikki Morley
councilor Jeff Morley councilor Liggett
councilor Tony Lacy
cancer Carol Lacy
councilor Kerry against councilor
William Jones
councilor Pam Jones
Council Higgins
cancer hartshorn Council Hancock
cancer
thank you Council Foster four
councilor Fletcher
Elsa Elliott
cancer Durant
cancer Dayton
cancer Dale or councilor Cupid or
Council Cornwall
Council Cooper Council Clough
Council Clegg
Council Cheatham yes Council Birkin
again councilor Beach
councilor Baxter
Council Barry
councilor Barker against Council Baker
and councilor adlington Stringer
to the leaflet headline against
[Music]
thank you
yeah
so the results of the vote for motion a
is 15 votes 4 30 against one abstention
so the motion is lost
so um item 14 Chairman's urgent business
just a reminder about the training
opportunity tomorrow with regard to
housing can I thank you very much for
your attendance and declare the meeting
closed
oh